zdf heute live einen schönen guten
morgen unser live stream immer zu
aktuellen themen und diskussionen keine
ausgangssperre mehr ein treffen mit
beliebig vielen menschen mit 19 genesene
und geimpfte können bald wieder mehr
freiheiten genießen der bundestag hat
dazu grünes licht gegeben gestern und
vor wenigen minuten auch der bundesrat
und wir schalten gleich zu der
pressekonferenz mit gesundheitsminister
sparen und präsident des lka professor
doktor wir schauen mal es geht gleich
los
du morgen liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz
wir begrüßen in diesem freitag auch an
diesem freitag den
bundesgesundheitsminister bahr und
sanierens sparen und an seiner seite den
präsidenten des robert koch instituts
professor lothar wieler herzlich
willkommen schön dass sie bei uns sind
ich denke herr sparen zu beginnen und
dann ihre bitte lieber adc meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren der trend der
letzten woche hat sich bestätigt die
dritte welle scheint gebrochen
die infektionszahlen sinken wieder aber
wir sind noch immer auf hohem niveau und
sie sinken noch nicht überall gleich
schnell
aber sie sinken grund dafür ist vor
allem das verhalten der bürgerinnen und
bürger sie haben die warnung ernst
genommen die einschränkung ernst
genommen sie haben kontakte reduziert
und das ist ja das was sozialen am
schwersten fällt sie haben ihre
mobilität reduziert und dafür können wir
nur ein herzliches dankeschön sagen die
diskussion zur notbremse die
beschlossenen maßnahmen die
beschränkungen die nicht leicht fallen
aber angesichts der lage notwendig waren
und sind haben dazu geführt diesen
positiven trend einzuleiten und diesen
trend den gilt es nun zu verstetigen
das geht aber nicht mit vorschnellen
lockerungen zu viele öffnen gerade
ziemlich viel bei relativ hoher ausgangs
instanz nummer zum vergleich das
vereinigte königreich wenn sie schauen
halt bei deutlich geringeren
infektionszahlen mit öffnung begonnen
das trägt auch ein risiko in sich dass
die zahlen wieder deutlich steigen das
sollten wir alle gemeinsam unbedingt
verhindern dass sie müssen wir weiterhin
alles dafür tun um im alltag infektionen
zu vermeiden steigende optimismus auch
berechtigte zuversicht dürfen jetzt
nicht dazu führen dass wir bei kontakt
und abstand uns nicht mehr an die regeln
halten sondern jetzt geht es gerade in
den nächsten drei vier wochen im grunde
vor allem dem individuellen kontakt
verhalten auch das fortzusetzen was wir
in den letzten drei wochen geschafft
dann gelingt es die erreichten den
erreichten trend auch zu sichern
und ich kann nur daran appellieren dass
da wohl lockerungen stattfinden
und natürlich auch jetzt nicht gerade
heute in berlin aber insgesamt mit dem
wetter und dem wunsch nach perspektive
dann lockerungen zu machen im
außenbereich außengastronomie
möglicherweise veranstaltungen
kultureller art draußen vor allem dann
auch vor zu sehen weil wir eben sehen
dass das infektionsrisiko draußen
deutlich geringer ist als in innenräumen
also wenn mit lockerungen bei einer
inzidenz unter 100 begonnen werden dann
vor allem draußen und dann vor allem
auch test gestützt auf das ist ja im
vergleich zu vor einigen monaten jetzt
auch möglich test gestützt auf breiter
front mögliche lockerungen vorzunehmen
und wie gesagt wenn bis jetzt schaffen
miteinander noch bis ende mai in etwa
auf das persönliche kontakt kontakt
verhalten sofort zu setzen wie in den
letzten drei wochen dann wird er schon
einen entscheidenden weiteren
unterschied machen also es braucht bei
aller zuversicht weiterhin umsicht und
vorsicht
nach dem bundestag hat gerade eben auch
der bundesrat die rechtsverordnung zu
den rechten von geimpften und genesenen
beschlossen
parallel dazu arbeiten wir an einer
rechtsverordnung mit dem wir mit der wir
den umgang mit geimpften und genesenen
bei einreise nach deutschland regeln
wollen auch hier soll gelten wer das
virus nicht mehr übertragen kann oder
kaum noch übertragen kann nach einer
effekt nach einer impfung oder einer
genesung der muss auch wieder mehr
freiheiten genießen vor allem braucht er
keine testpflicht mehr und auch keine
quarantäne bei der rückkehr ausnahme
wichtig bei virusvarianten gebieten also
dort wo es möglicherweise mutationen
gibt die auch etwa die im wirksamkeit
beeinträchtigen die neuen regeln fallen
in eine zeit in der die impfkampagne
weiter an fahrt aufnimmt die zahlen von
heute morgen die impfungen von gestern
wir haben 26,2 millionen deutsche
mindestens einmal geimpft worden sind
das sind 31
prozent mit dieser entwicklung werden
wir in der nächsten woche dann jeden
dritten mindestens einmal geimpft haben
können
8,8 prozent haben den vollen schutz und
sind zweimal geimpft
das waren damit gestern 932 1000
impfungen also ein weiterer tag wo mehr
als ein prozent der bevölkerung
innerhalb eines tages geimpft worden ist
damit sind wir durchaus auch im
internationalen vergleich im moment
zumindest ziemlich auf der überholspur
ist vielleicht viel öfter auch dass
deutschland dann er gut ist im
elfmeterschießen und sich dann gut auch
entwickelt im laufe der kampagne war
sehr sehr wichtig ist dass wir gestern
einmal mehr um die 200.000 zweitimpfung
hatten wir haben sehr sehr starken fokus
gehabt auf die erstimpfung aber nicht
zuletzt mit der entscheidung heute im
bundesrat und gestern im bundestag
natürlich sind die zweitimpfung für den
vollen schutz sehr wichtig und mit etwa
200.000 zweitimpfung gestern auch dort
eine sehr sehr hohe zahl
voraussetzung ist dass wir das auch
fortsetzen können ist dass wir nicht
nachlassen beim tempo bei der
impfkampagne deshalb haben wir gestern
mit dem gesundheitsministerin und
ministern der länder beschlossen die
priorisierung der astra zenica
aufzuheben nach aufklärung durch den
arzt und nach einer risikoabwägung soll
es jedem und jeder möglich sein sich mit
diesem wachsen impfen zu lassen und dem
impfen den arzt dort ist in absprache
mit dem zu impfenden freistehen den
abstand zwischen erster und zweiter im
rahmen der zulassung tatsächlich dann
auch zu wählen wichtig ist zu beachten
die wirksamkeit ist umso höher desto
länger
der abstand zwischen erster und zweiter
ist und das sollen arzt und zu impfen da
dann innerhalb der zulassung miteinander
auch besprechen und entscheiden können
wir sind überzeugt davon dass dieses
angebot vor allem für diejenigen
attraktiv sein wird die sonst eben nicht
so schnell im moment an eine impfung
bekommen würden allein nächste woche
werden wir über eine
astrazeneca dosen an die arztpraxen
ausliefern
und die können dann zur wm kommen das
zeigt aber auch um jetzt auch die
arztpraxen und ihre teams heute morgen
zu schützen
es können jetzt nicht innerhalb
natürlich von drei oder fünf tagen oder
auch von zwei wochen alle geimpft werden
stehen dosen zur verfügung es werden
allein nächste woche eine million astra
zenica dosen an die arztpraxen
ausgeliefert aber natürlich auch mit
freigabe jetzt der priorisierung für
diesen impfstoff dauert als auch dort
seine zeit ist die angebote dann haben
erfolgen können
abschließend die letzten monate waren
hart auch wenn im internationalen auch
im europäischen vergleich viele andere
noch härter getroffen worden sind es gab
und gibt viel leid und viele härten und
gleichzeitig sehen wir dass wir
insgesamt bis hierhin ist geschafft
haben der zweiten in der dritten welle
mit niedrigeren instanzen als auch in
vielen nachbarstaaten durch diese wellen
zu kommen mit im verhältnis auch weniger
todesopfer noch gleich natürlich jeder
todesfall einer zu viel ist der zu
beklagen ist unser gesundheitswesen ist
zwar stark gefordert aber zu keinem
zeitpunkt überfordert gewesen
wir haben große schritte nach vorne
gemacht wer menschen ich habs gerade
beschrieben aber vor allem auch beim
aufbau der test infrastruktur die jetzt
die möglichkeit gibt
idealerweise bei weiter gesunkenen
infektionszahlen abgesichert öffnung
schritte zurückzugehen
jetzt geht es darum den nächsten wochen
noch gemeinsam durchzuhalten wir reden
tatsächlich jetzt noch über wochen oder
wenige monate im moment ist jeder tag
lang und hart das ist uns sehr sehr
bewusst aber in dieser phase der
pandemie geht es eben tatsächlich weit
darum weiterhin darum das erreichte
nicht zu verspielen
deswegen braucht es zuversicht gepaart
mit umsicht um menschen zu schützen zu
viel ungeduld dagegen würde nur dem
virus helfen danke sehr gut morgen meine
damen und herren
seit ende april diesen jahres gehen die
fallzahlen leicht zurück die bundesweite
7 tages inzidenz ist
man kann auf 126 gesunden die instanzen
sind tatsächlich in allen altersgruppen
gesunden gleichzeitig werden immer mehr
menschen gegen kuwait 19 geimpft das ist
eine sehr erfreuliche nachricht auf den
intensivstationen ist momentan leider
noch keine entspannung sichtbar wir
sehen auch glücklicherweise hierzu einen
ersten rückgang der patientenzahlen
allerdings nur bei den leichteren fällen
die zahl der patienten die invasiv
beatmet werden muss oder sogar eine
behandlung benötigt die steigt aber
teilweise immer noch an über 70 prozent
der intensiv bereiche welt dass ihre
kapazitäten begrenzt oder sogar
ausgelastet sind
das sind höchstwerte meine damen und
herren in dieser pandemie und leider
werden dafür vor viele todesfälle an das
robert koch institut gemeldet
an manchen tagen sind es ja weiterhin
mehrere hundert die gegenwärtige
entwicklung mit sinkenden inzidenz in
einer zumindest leicht sinkenden
belegung mit co at 19 patienten auf den
intensivstationen und einer steigenden
durch impfung ist sehr positiv
einzige hoffnung dass wir die pandemie
bald kontrollieren können dennoch sind
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt neben den
weiterlaufenden impfungen auch immer
noch weitere maßnahmen zur kontakt
reduktion nötig also die einhaltung der
bekannten regeln abstand halten
hygieneregeln atemmasken tragen
mundschutz tagen lüften und warum das so
ist das möchte ich ihnen heute gerne ein
wenig näher erläutern mit einer
überschlagsrechnung hierzu muss ich
nochmal zunächst auf den herr wert
eingehen der angibt wie viele personen
zb von hunderte infizierten angesteckt
werden für die neue variante b 11 7 das
wissen sie die jetzt vor herrscht mehr
als 90 prozent aller fälle sind auf
diese variante zurückzuführen ist der
wert etwa 4
das bedeutet ohne massnahmen und in
einer nicht immunen bevölkerung würden
100 infizierte
400 menschen anstellen und diese 400
würden dann wiederum 1600 anstecken und
so weiter das virus würde sich also sehr
schnell verbreiten und es kam zu einer
neuen welle für die eindämmung der
pandemie ist deshalb so wichtig dass der
wert stabil unter 1 bleibt bei hohen
fallzahlen ist das natürlich besonders
wichtig so was hatten in deutschland
werden in deutschland seit februar wert
zwischen etwa 1,1 und 1,3 sagen wir mal
der lag also bei 1,2 dann sind die
fallzahlen ja erneut gestiegen
sie erinnern sich das bedeutet aber auch
dass wir alle dass sie also wir alle
haben zusammen nur durch kontakt
reduzierende maßnahmen und hygieneregeln
den erwerb von b17 daher bei 4 legt den
haben wir runter gedrückt auf 1,2 allein
das ist schon eine großartige leistung
das haben wir zusammen geschafft ja das
hat die ganze bevölkerung zusammen
geschafft
seit mitte april ist nun der erwert
weitergesungen er liegt momentan bei
etwa 0,9
dann würden also 100 infizierte nicht
wie bei 4 400 anstecken sondern 90
anstecken das liegt man daran dass sie
alle ihren kontakte weiterhin sehr
deutlich eingeschränkt haben vielleicht
auch ein wenig nichts am frühlingswetter
man kann er dann mehr draußen sein
wir wissen dass das ansteckungsrisiko
drinnen viel höher ist als draußen und
zum teil liegt das natürlich auch eine
impfquote die impfquote liegt derzeit
bei etwas über 30 prozent
meist sind es erst impfungen bei denen
der schutz aber noch nicht so stark ist
gehen wir mal davon aus für die
berechnung die ich jetzt mit ihm
durchgehen dass die schutzwirkung der
erstimpfung bei ungefähr 70 prozent
liegt also sieben von zehn werden
geschützt
das heißt also dann sind 70 prozent von
den 30 prozent geimpften davor geschützt
sich mit dem virus anzustecken momentan
wir können dann also grob überschlagen
dass momentan etwa 20 prozent
also von einer von fünf oder 20 von 100
der bevölkerung vor einer infektion
geschützt sind und somit auch niemand
anderen anstecken können 20 prozent
momentan das ist ja das großartige an
info man schützt ja nicht nur sich
selber vor der impfung sondern man
schützt ja auch noch die anderen mit
nehmen wir nun an dass die impfungen der
bevölkerung gleich verteilt sind auch
dass die kontakte zwischen geimpft und
nicht geimpften gleich verteilt sind das
ist natürlich nicht korrekt aber für die
berechnung nehmen wir das einfach mal an
wie gesagt bedeutet die aktuelle
impfquote das im zusammenspiel mit dem
impfschutz vor ansteckungen dass etwa 20
prozent der infektion verhindert damit
sinkt der wert von 1,2 auf 0,9 600
personen infizieren hat also nicht mehr
120 personen nur noch 96
das ist grob vereinfacht die jetzige
situation in der wir uns momentan
befinden kontakt reduzierende maßnahmen
und impfungen haben es geschafft dass
für den erwerb unter 1 drücken
die pandemie ist quasi wie ein prall
gefüllter luftballon den wir zusammen
unter der wasseroberfläche halten
das tun wir gemeinsam mit diesem
kraftakt den wir seit vielen monaten
durchhalten wenn wir jetzt schlagartig
alle maßnahmen aufheben würden dann wäre
der wert erst mal wieder bei vieren
durch die impfung mit dem jetzigen stand
würde um 20 prozent gedrückt dh der
resultierende er wert wäre dann bei 3,2
das heißt dass von 100 infizierten
wiederum 320 angesteckt würden und diese
würden dann wiederum 1024 anstecken und
so weiter ein exponentielles wachstum
das virus wurde ist also rasant
ausbreiten um im bild zu bleiben wenn
wir den ballon jetzt loslassen springt
er über die wasseroberfläche
wir dürfen also nicht ungezielt locker
von woche zu woche nimmt aber die
durchimpfung zu daher können nach und
nach auch einzelne maßnahmen
zurückgenommen werden ohne dass der wert
erneut steigt der balance verliert
sozusagen langsam luft und es braucht
aber immer weniger kraft um den unten zu
halten
aber nochmal er hat noch genug luft und
noch brauchen wir die kraft und noch
muss die reihenfolge stimmen sündig im
kontrolliert öffnen je höher die
impfquote desto mehr fälle werden wir
verhindern können je höher die impfquote
kann man maßnahmen lockern die steigende
impfquote wird in absehbarer zeit sehr
spürbare erleichterungen bringen
bisher aber weitgehend auf maßnahmen
träge verzichten können denn er wird
aber weiter unter 1 halten muss der
anteil der immunen person in der
bevölkerung entweder durch eine
vollständige impfung oder durch eine
durchgemachte infektion plus impfung bei
der vorherrschenden virus variante b 11
7 deutlich über 80 prozent liegen
auch dann wird es neue infektionen geben
es wird doch noch ausbrüche geben aber
es wird keine wellen mehr geben dann
haben wir die pandemie unter kontrolle
und wir können davon ausgehen dass bei
einer immunität von weit über 80 prozent
schwere verläufe und todesfälle zum
großen teil verhindert werden eine
impfquote von mindestens 80%
vollständige impfung bei den erwachsenen
wird daher auch von der
weltgesundheitsorganisation als
zielmarke ausgegeben
darum kann ich sie und uns alle nur
weiter bitte noch ein bisschen geduld
aufzubringen
wir haben viel zusammen geschafft sorgen
wir nun dafür dass wir auf der letzten
strecke nicht zu viele weitere menschen
verlieren schwere krankheitsfälle sehen
oder auch menschen die später an longo
wird noch leiden werden wenn wir zu
viele schritte zu schnell auf einmal
machen
wir haben vieles erreicht und wir können
den rest des weges auch noch genauso gut
weitergehen damit viele viele menschen
gesund bleiben in unserem land vielen
dank
wir haben sehr viele fragen im raum und
von außen und wir versuchen das in der
zeit bis 11 uhr möglichst viele
drankommen ergeben fängt an dann der
kollege heinz weiter hinten 3 sie haben
es erspart ist ein griff an der
augsburger ich wollte sie fragen
dieser aspekt ist in den letzten wochen
etwas in den hintergrund getreten
aber die gesundheitsämter verfolgen ja
nach wie vor die infektionsketten auch
wenn das nicht mehr diskutiert wird ist
wie ist denn da mittlerweile der stand
also haben die dieses systemische update
durchgeführt also andere nachverfolgung
systeme mittlerweile aufgespielt und
zweitens was wird man tun
nach der pandemie damit dass in einer
weiteren welle nicht mehr passiert dass
die gesundheitsämter überfordert zuerst
einmal ergeben ich tippe sie meinen
unter anderem sommers und die vernetzung
der gesundheitsämter ist es so dass ich
habe jetzt nicht auf eine prozentzahl
ist liefern wegen gern nach gut 80
prozent der gesundheitsämter sommers
betriebsbereit haben
der entscheidende nächste schritt und
der ist jetzt auch wichtig für das was
wir eigentlich erreichen wollen ist das
so genannte super six steht für exchange
austausch das dann insbesondere auch das
system sommers erstens sozusagen es
möglich macht dass das gesundheitsamt in
rosenheim mit dem in flensburg direkt
auch zb kontaktpersonen wenn da ein
ausbruch ist nach einer veranstaltung
und es kommt jemand aus einem anderen
gesundheitsamts bezirk dann die daten
austauschen kann aber eben auch die
schnittstellen zu den anderen software
es so da sind das dann viel besser
vielleicht auch mit höherer akzeptanz
die dinge entsprechend umgesetzt werden
können
ich weiß dass wir etwas hinter dem
zeitplan sind es bleibt gleichwohl eine
historische das hat schon eine
historische dimension dass wir zum
ersten mal dann die gesundheitsämter in
deutschland tatsächlich vollständig
vernetzen
sie sind weiterhin natürlich
eigenständig aber sind in einem
verbunden zusammen mini zuvor und das
digitale macht das natürlich in einer
art und weise und in einer direkt
information ermöglicht die so vor 20
jahren auch noch nicht gegangen wäre
aber dieses vernetzen der
gesundheitsämter ist mindestens eine
zehn jahre alte debatte also auch dem
ist das digital das elektronische
meldesystem schiff glaube ich zehn
jahren im gesetz seit dem ersten ist es
endlich auch bei 100 prozent das zum
beispiel bei saas 52 die labore
elektronisch melden und für die anderen
infektionskrankheiten dem meldepflichtig
sind wird auch das ausgerollt also
genauen zahlen liefern wie nach aber es
steigt gerade täglich die zahl der
beteiligten gesundheitsämter und aus
meiner sicht ist das jetzt auch ein
unumkehrbarer entwicklung so sich auch
vereinbart mit den ländern dass das der
standard wird für die 20er jahre im
austausch miteinander über die pandemie
hinaus haben wir den pakt für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
geschlossenen bund länder und kommunale
spitzenverbände
dieser pakt war ja bewusst nicht jetzt
die kurzfrist maßnahme sondern eben die
mittel- und langfristiges name was
unterstützung beim personalausbau und
aufbau an geht über drei milliarden die
der bund für personalaufbau im
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienste
investiert 800 millionen in die digitale
infrastruktur und ausstattung bis 2025
und auch dort sind über die
umsatzsteueranteile ganz technisch aber
jedenfalls die gelder fürs personal bei
den ländern und damit auch bei den
kommunen angekommen
die programme was das digitale angeht
was übrigens auch dass er tüchtigen
unserer flug und seehäfen angeht auch
das ist ein wichtiges thema das wir da
wo international reiseverkehr
stattfindet diese flughäfen und seehäfen
auch entsprechend der tüchtigen für
entsprechende maßnahmen im fall der
fälle auch dieses investitionsprogramm
ist gerade in der vorbereitung so dass
wir eben parallel zur akuten pandemie
auch die mittel- und langfristig namen
umsätzen gut der kollege hier ein
neudenken haben im körper vom zdf herr
minister wie erklären sie denn zum
beispiel indern dass die bundesregierung
jetzt etwa 100 beatmungsgeräte in dieses
riesige land schickt aber beim
patentschutz hart bleibt ist sind die
gewinne der pharmakonzerne
schützenswerte half menschen leben in
indien also zuerst einmal sind wir auch
grundsätzlich bereit mehr
beatmungsgeräte zu schicken auf
nachfrage ist aber akut kein weiterer
bedarf gewesen sobald bedarf da ist
unterstützen wir gerne übrigens nicht
nur mit beatmungsgeräten wir haben auch
medikamente rendite unter anderem zur
verfügung gestellt und schutzausrüstung
zum zweiten die diskussion hatten wir
glaube ich vor einer woche hier auch
schon und daran hat sich jetzt auch
nichts geändert durch den gestrigen tag
das hauptthema ist nicht die frage von
patenten das hauptthema ist die frage
von produktionskapazitäten und gerade
eben stoffe zu produzieren ist nichts
was man mal eben perle
dann irgendwo in irgend einer fabrik
irgendwie machen kann ob jetzt die in
deutschland steht oder indien oder viele
sondern das geht es richtig um
technologietransfer
das muss man können und
technologietransfer ist in aller regel
besser in kooperation als dass da
irgendwie widerstand ist zum zweiten
haben wir wie ich finde zu recht die
forscherteams gefeiert für das was sie
geschafft haben innerhalb von wenigen
wochen und monaten für uns zu entwickeln
dass wir über all das reden können
worüber wir gerade reden rund ums impfen
hat was zu tun mit forscher und
innovationsgeist und die forscherinnen
und forscher finde ich am zumindest mal
mit ihren auch forscher rechten schon
zumindest mal im blickpunkt in dieser
debatte verdient und das bringt mich zum
dritten teil wenn das eigentliche
problem nicht
patente sind sondern
produktionskapazitäten und verfügbarkeit
dann freue ich mich ja wenn die
vereinigten staaten von amerika genauso
wie die europäische union nun mehr
bereit sind dosen die produziert worden
sind in den usa auch für den export
freizugeben
das ist doch die eigentliche frage die
europäische union produziert für die
welt es war auch durchaus bewusst in
verantwortung für die welt und in dem
wissen dass wir alle erst sicher sind
wenn alle sicher sind auf der welt und
deswegen exportieren wir und werden noch
deutlich mehr exportieren
es ist ja absehbar wenn sie nur die
zahlen und mengen dem bajonett will zwei
bis drei millionen 2 3 milliarden dosen
jahresproduktion haben und dazuhin
hochfahren wir werden noch viel mehr
exportiert ich kann es nur begrüßen wenn
die vereinigten staaten ihre bisherige
politik dort verändern und auch
impfdosen für andere länder zur
verfügung stehen
der zusatz indien und südafrika sagen
sie haben die produktionskapazitäten
ihren die produktionskapazitäten für mma
im stoff der nicht durch kooperation
gedeckt werden kann also ich es gibt ja
es gibt eine tatsächlich produktion in
kooperation in beiden ländern
es gibt übrigens auch eine kooperation
mit china was den m a im stau
angeht und wenn es konkrete punkte gibt
wo noch mehr kooperation möglich sind
helfen wir gerne mit diese kooperationen
zu befördern
aber ich finde jetzt irgendwie in der
frage auch welchen anspruch wir in der
europa und der europäischen union haben
dann gilt es eben auch innovation und
forschergeist der hier bei uns in europa
ist ja der welt verfügbar zu machen und
übrigens es gibt wir sind das land
deutschland das sich am zweitmeisten am
zweithöchsten engagierte kovacs also wir
engagieren uns in all diesen bereichen
und wo es nötig ist werden wir uns auch
zusätzlich finanziell und in taten und
in kooperations unterstützung engagieren
gleichzeitig möchte ich aber auch
sicherstellen dass mit innovationen und
entwicklungen die es in der europäischen
union erlebt wie auch verantwortlich
umgehen
gut dann ist gleich vergessen dran es
gab zu dem thema patente gab es auch
fragen von außen zb vom polona vierhaus
aus slowenien ich gehe mal davon aus
dass die damit beantwortet sind sonst
müsste da noch mal über das frage tool
nachgelegt werden zunächst harrison und
dann wieder links zu den kollegen bitte
ja die frage schließt sich direkt daran
ersparen die haben eben selber gesagt
dass indien wohl auch technologisch die
kapazitäten hätte auf einem herrn
impfstoffe in dem moment liegt es dann
aber eben doch dürfen die oder nicht was
spricht also nochmal dagegen wenn man
durch eine zeitweilige patent freigabe
ländern und indien ist der größte
arzneimittel produzent der welt dort wo
kapazitäten vorhanden sind
in es auch ermöglicht sie zu nutzen sie
haben eigentlich gerade eben ihr eigenes
hauptargument ausgegeben
indem sie sagten ja indien kann das
eigene den satz habe ich nicht gesagt
unabhängig davon so wie sie ihn gerade
formulieren aber sie haben ihn so
verstanden das ist okay
gut also wenn die inder die frage des
kollegen körper wahr gewesen indien sagt
wir haben die kapazitäten das
herzustellen
eben haben sie zugestimmt vielleicht
habe ich sie da falsch verstanden aber
wie gesagt wenn indien und andere große
impfstoffhersteller
sagen wir haben die kapazitäten wir
können das aufbauen
warum sollten nicht durch zeitweilige
patent freigabe das ermöglicht werden
und professor wieder sie waren lange
zeit selbst in der forschung
die bundesregierung begrüßt die nicht
zustimmung zu einer patent freigabe
damit dass das geistige eigentum auch
zukünftig die grundlage für die mutation
bleiben müsse ist es tatsächlich so dass
deutsche forscher nicht mehr erforschen
würden wenn patente zeitweilig
freigegeben werden
also zuerst einmal ist es jetzt eine
behauptung in der fragestellung mir ist
das nicht bekannt dass es konkrete
angebote aus indien und vor allem
nachweise gibt sozusagen morgen am tag
ohne weiteren technologietransfer das zu
können das würde mich insofern wundern
als das ist schon die partner wie sanofi
ohne technologietransfer über wochen und
monate nicht schaffen mal eben von einem
tag auf den anderen rna produktionen
oder auch abfüllungen zu machen es
braucht ja vorbereitung etwa in
frankfurt in der kooperation wie in
anderen bereichen auch und deswegen wie
geht es nie ohne technologietransfer
erster zweiter teil ich sage noch einmal
ich meine es ist ja nicht ungeschickt
die debatte jetzt zu führen also dass
der staat sozusagen der bis jetzt mit am
wenigsten dem rest der welt zur
verfügung gestellt hat jetzt die debatte
so rum beginnt ist eine interessante
wendung nämlich auch alles zur kenntnis
sprechen wir auch alles miteinander
aber ich finde es weiterhin den
entscheidenden teilen den entscheidenden
schritt impfstoffe für die welt zu
produzieren zur verfügung zu stellen und
vor allem auch eben bezahlbar zu machen
und das ist das was die bundesregierung
tut das ist das was die europäische
union tut um gleichzeitig haben wir auch
als innovationsstandort das sage ich
auch schon auch ein interesse daran dass
natürlich ist auch eigentum gibt
geistiges eigentum gibt und das ist
bestehende rechte gibt und wir haben in
den letzten monaten doch eins gesehen
die debatten
wir vor vier monaten schon mal haben
gesagt wir müssten in deutschland auf
zwangs produktionen manche haben sogar
die ganz andere wortwahl noch gemacht
umstellen was wir gesehen haben ist
schauen sie einfach auf die letzten vier
monate eine vielzahl von kooperationen
von zusammenarbeit von den willen
getragen für europa und die welt
ausreichend impfstoff herzustellen
wenn ich irgendwo anders hätte daran zu
zweifeln dass die unternehmen alles da
nicht alles dafür täten
produktionsmengen buch zu bringen und
produktionskapazitäten zu bringen um die
welt zu versorgen
dann würde ich mich ja auch manches ein
gedankengang noch eher ein lassen aber
das ist doch nicht der fall
das ist eine debatte wie eigentlich
nicht das eigentliche problem adressiert
sein wenn es einen indischen hersteller
gibt tatsächlich sagt ich kenne kein er
könnte morgen am tag amerika produzieren
und zu braucht ein kooperationspartner
dann helfen wir gerne mit eine solche
kooperation möglich zu machen
nächste wahl verliert
das ist eine interessante frage die man
offen diskutieren sollte ja wie kann ich
ihnen nicht beantworten ich gehe davon
aus dass die mehrzahl der kolleginnen
und kollegen die gerade im
biomedizinischen bereich forschen dass
die natürlich forschen
weil die damit ein ergebnis heraus
bringen wollen das dann letztlich auch
zum menschen kommt und dazu führt dass
die gesundheit verbessert wird und da
ist das dann die frage des patents ist
natürlich eine motivation dabei aber ich
kann ihnen die frage nicht beantworten
ist eine interessante frage die man
tatsächlich mal diskutieren sollte im
wissenschafts kontext der minister eine
frage zur wied medikamenten
es sind ja mal für 400 millionen euro
antikörper national mittel aus den usa
gekauft worden die zum teil ihrer not
zulassung verloren haben die
bundesrepublik zu beklagen sich
unternehmen in deutschland versäumtes
die vielversprechende forschung an cupid
medikamenten zu unterstützen so dass im
ergebnis noch immer keine wirksame
medikamente haben was sagen sie dazu
zuerst einmal die monoklonalen
antikörper
sind weiterhin tatsächlich nicht
zugelassen das ist so die
zulassungsverfahren laufen insbesondere
bei dem einen von den beiden beschaffen
ist es zusätzlich eine
kombinationstherapie ein zweites
medikament dass wir auch mittlerweile
auch mittlerweile beschafft haben
alles was man bisher sieht ist es so
dass bei infizierten die ein erhöhtes
oder sehr hohes risiko haben für einen
schweren oder schwersten verlauf eine
sehr frühzeitige gabe dieser medikamente
tatsächlich diese schwersten verläufe
vermeidet es rettet leben
deswegen haben wir mittlerweile auch mit
einer verordnung auch die vergütung
geregelt für die ärzte für die
krankenhäuser die es tun
wir müssen sehen das ist eine infusion
das ist nicht viel oder soll es eine
infusion die braucht drei bis vier
stunden auch dann ärztliche begleitung
das ist ein aufwand der vergütet werden
muss auch das ist mittlerweile geregelt
und ein breiterer einsatz mit der
richtigen zielgruppe natürlich nämlich
patienten mit einem erhöhten risiko
hilft menschenleben zu retten
zum zweiten was die frage angeht der
medikamenten forschungsförderung in
deutschland gibt es bereits zwei
förderprogramme des
forschungsministeriums und es ist gerade
ein drittes finale in der freigabe der
federführend von uns finanziert zusammen
mit dem forschungsministerium auch
entwickelt und in der abwicklung über
die kollegen und deren ressourcen dort
das ist die frau bundesministerin
carlitscheck und ich ja auch jetzt
zeitnah werden gemeinsam vorstellen
können der haushaltsgesetzgeber dafür
300 millionen euro zusätzlich noch
wieder vorgesehen
und da geht es vor allem um medikamente
in der phase 2b drei oder auch schon mit
blick auf produktionsförderung
unterstützung wir tun also auch dort
vieles um entsprechende forschung in
deutschland zu unterstützen
aber ich erlebt manchmal das gleiche was
sich bei maskenmann sich bei tests was
sich auch in anderen bereichen erlebt
habe dass die öffentlich immer darauf
hinweisen dass sie nicht unterstützt
werden im zweifel nicht diejenigen sind
die schon immer am weitesten sind aber
dafür haben sie medial umso mehr
durchschlagskraft das ist ein
interessantes phänomen dass ich über die
letzten 14 monate in
den aspekten habe verfolgen können wir
konzentrieren uns aber nicht nach der
frage wer mediale durchschlagskraft hat
sondern wer tatsächlich gute studien
dann gut jetzt wie man fragen von außen
basil wegener von der db a fragt was der
sachliche grund für die freigabe von
astrazeneca ist der entschluss zum
beispiel bei der gruppe über 60
unbeliebt besteht nicht die gefahr dass
jüngere ihn nehmen und die zweitimpfung
trotz geringerer wirksamkeit schon nach
vier wochen machen um früher in den
urlaub fahren zu können
also zuerst einmal ist es so dass je
nach bundesland aber etwa 70 prozent der
über 60 jährigen eine erste impfung
haben damit also die frage welcher
impfstoff welche im freie für die über
60 jährigen in den allermeisten fällen
schon entschieden ist die zweite impfung
ist noch nicht überall erfolgt aber die
erstimpfung ist david zumal ja auch
nicht mit einer hundertprozentigen
impfbereitschaft wahrscheinlich leider
nicht rechnen können wenn wir jetzt mal
positiv von 80 plus - ausgehen sind die
allermeisten über 60 jährigen noch nicht
alle aber die allermeisten die sich
impfen lassen wollen
tatsächlich schon mit einem impfangebot
konkret oder inside nach der terminus
zeichner vergeben
und nun stellt sich natürlich die frage
auch für die weitere impfkampagne wie
wir insgesamt das tempo auch halten
können und ich jedenfalls kenne viele
die bereit sind in individueller
entscheidung nach ärztliche aufklärung
in kenntnis des sehr seltenen aber
vorhandenen risikos tatsächlich sich mit
astra zenica impfen lassen zu wollen
gleichzeitig berichten uns die
arztpraxen dass es für sie immer
schwerer wird überhaupt das thema
priorisierung gerade bei diesem
impfstoff irgendwie noch zu händeln wie
das insgesamt ja damit dass wir jetzt in
der priorisierung gruppe drei sind es
immer schwieriger wird das zu händeln
deswegen habe ich auch gesagt jetzt ist
noch einmal die priorisierung wichtig
vor allem für die die seit vier monaten
warten
verkäuferinnen und verkäufer
justizbeamte lehrerinnen und lehrer
viele andere die keine home office
machen können journalistinnen und
journalisten sind in vielen
bundesländern ja auch dabei und dann
im juni die priorisierung ganz
aufzuheben oder astra zenica machen wir
diesen schritt jetzt tatsächlich früher
die frage des intervalls bei den zweit
impfungen
es ist wieder die frage herr wähler wird
im zweifel sagen und ich im zweifel auch
umso länger das intervall desto
wirksamer das ist so gleichzeitig ist
die zulassung und die zulassungsdaten
auf vier bis sechs wochen ausgelegt und
es habe auch viele ärztinnen und ärzte
tatsächlich uns berichtet dass sie
zumindest mal etwas flexibler sein
können wollen wenn sie es jetzt zehn
wochen acht wochen 600 sich also ich
glaube nicht dass jetzt die allermeisten
auf vier wochen gehen werden aber ich
traue auch den ärzten die ansonsten
übrigens auch nach einer zulassung
entscheiden innerhalb welchen intervalls
die zweitimpfung stattfindet dass sie
der verantwortliche entscheidungen
treffen aber eines bleibt halt war
wir müssen uns jetzt hier nicht
irgendwie geschichten erzählen dass
jetzt anfang mai menschen angesichts
auch der entscheidung was ist bei
vollständig geimpften noch erforderlich
und was nicht sagen wenn jetzt die
zweitimpfung anfang mai plus drei monate
irgendwann im august ist dann habe ich
irgendwie keine richtige lust auf diesen
impfstoff ist jetzt auch eine zutiefst
menschliche reaktion die ich jedenfalls
es ist jetzt sozusagen spanische empirie
jenseits dessen was uns die erste
zurückmelden allein schon in meinem
weiteren bekanntenkreis im ganzen
münsterland aber an rückmeldung bekommen
neben sagen kann man es nicht zumindest
mal etwas verkürzen
und da die zulassung ist möglich macht
sagen wir einerseits um so länger desto
besser und geben es gleichzeitig in eine
verantwortete entscheidung des arztes
und des zu impfenden innerhalb der
zulassung das miteinander zu vereinbaren
in jedem fall ist es besser es werden
menschen mit astra zenica geimpft als
dass sie nicht geimpft werden also der
schutz ist in jedem fall höher und der
ist in dieser phase der pandemie
professor wieler hat gerade darauf
hingewiesen wie schon nach erstimpfung
der schutz
ein relativ guter ist der ist in dieser
phase der pandemie unbedingt notwendig
dass wir das auch zügig machen
beim versuch das mal zusammen zu nehmen
zwei fragen zu bereits infiziert markus
kredel in der rede erfragt viele
menschen haben sich 2020 infiziert ohne
einen pcr-test machen zu können brauchen
diese menschen auch zwei impfungen und
um einen e mobilitäts ausweis zu
bekommen oder wie soll mit diesen
menschen umgegangen werden und und
gisela groll fragt professor wille auf
welche studien stützen sich ihre
annahmen dass genesene zusätzlich einmal
geimpft werden müssen und zudem
tatsächlich immunen zu gehören
also zuerst einmal die frage wie es
genießen dann nachweis definiert ist
tatsächlich mit der verordnung eindeutig
geregelt das ist ein pcr test und der
nachweis eines entsprechenden pc
ältestes und genesen ist ab 28 tage nach
sozusagen datum der testung bis sechs
monate und dann ist die dann gelten
sozusagen die aufnahmen gleich wenn die
sechs monate um sind erfordert ist
zusätzlich eine impfung und damit ist
andersrum auch definiert dass alle
anderen konstellationen nicht darunter
fallen warum zum beispiel ein antikörper
nachweis nicht weil der eine
unterschiedlich gute aussagekraft
darüber hat insbesondere übrigens auch
wann diese infektion stattgefunden hat
nämlich nahezu gar keine
dafür ist es zu unterschiedlich auch in
der antikörper antwort bei denjenigen
die die infektion durchgemacht haben und
deutsch ist dann eben im zweifel
tatsächlich ein impfschema mit zwei
impfungen dann vorgesehen ja es gibt
meines wissens zwei studien ich glaube
eines im jugendjournal mädels in einem
lancet publiziert wo daten über die
genesenen und sowas und die verabreichen
von einem impfstoff drinsteht wir haben
ich glaube heute oder morgen oder
gestern ich bin ich mir ganz sicher
haben wir auch in
publikation nochmal epidemische
projektor darüber verfasst wie es mit
dem immunschutz sind aussieht nach
impfungen und auch den von genesen
also das heißt es gibt dafür daten das
ist keine ganz hohe überzeugende evidenz
aber es gibt genügend daten und die
sagen uns dass die menschen wenn die
infiziert waren
ein großer teil von denen wirklich sechs
monate lang einen immunschutz hat und
wenn wir dann den immunschutz quasi
boostern mit einer impfung dann ist nach
den parametern die man bisher messen
kann und das ist wie gesagt es sind
nicht sehr viele studien
dann haben die einen sehr sehr guten
immunschutz also zwei publikationen vor
allem wir dazu ein näheres ist in dieser
publikation beschriebenes gerade sagen
vielleicht noch mal einen hinweis an
alle weil auch immer wieder diese fragen
zur quelle kommt von informationen
ich glaube es wäre wirklich sehr schön
wenn alle die stiko app herunterladen
weil die stiko app gibt auch immer ganz
aktuell die informationen die stiko app
macht auch schöne grafiken teilt auch
gute videos wo über die impfungen
berichtet wird haben sie eine quelle
quasi ein portal wo immer die aktuellen
daten über impfungen zu cockpit auch
zusammengefasst werden auch zu anderen
und da finden sie diese information alle
ganz lieb und meine frage von außen dann
kommen wir im saal zu herrn jung und
frisch rasmus buchsteiner von pioneer
fragt den minister sie haben diese woche
noch einmal neue mittel genehmigt
bekommen für die impfstoff beschaffung
bis 2023 wann muss eigentlich neue
geimpft werden nach einem halben jahr
anderthalb jahren oder wissen wir das
noch nicht genau
also zum ersten was die frage angeht der
mittel für 2022 23 ist das tatsächlich
auch nur ein erster bedarf ein großer
von knapp vier milliarden euro aber ein
erster bedarf gewesen für jetzt ein
ist ja auch in der presse in den medien
gewesen einen zusätzlichen vertrag in
die europäische kommission mit beyond
advisor für 2022 23 final gerade in den
verhandlungen hat und dafür müssen wir
natürlich dann auch für 2022 23 nach
haushaltsrechtliche grundlage haben und
die haben wir durch den
haushaltsausschuss und das
finanzministerium in dieser woche kommen
es kann aber durchaus sein ist sogar
sehr wahrscheinlich dass wir auch
weitere mittel werden brauchen wenn
weitere verträge anstehen
wir werden sehr auch für 20 22 und 23
für ein portfolio ansatz heißt also
nicht nur auf einen hersteller auch
nicht nur auf eine technologie zu setzen
ist ob es so ein breites portfolio sein
muss jetzt das denke ich nicht aber
zumindest mal noch ein oder zwei weitere
technologien im dna technologie
mindestens noch zwei drei weitere
hersteller sollen ist aus unserer sicht
auch sein und die diskussion findet
gerade zwischen den mitgliedstaaten
stadt die frage wann eine
auffrischimpfung notwendig ist dazu gibt
es tatsächlich noch keine guten
erkenntnisse die kann man ja auch erst
im zeitablauf gewinnen
also wir können ja ein schon mal
ziemlich sicher sagen nach den
erkenntnissen die wir haben es wird
jetzt geimpft seit dezember
wir haben jetzt anfang mai also
jedenfalls hält es auf jeden fall schon
mal gute vier monate und im moment keine
anzeichen dafür dass jetzt innerhalb der
nächsten wochen eine dritte impfung
auffrischimpfung notwendig wäre es gibt
ja auch die probanden aus den ersten
klinischen studien die allerersten sind
ja geimpft worden schon vor über einem
jahr in dem ersten klinischen studien
und auch dort ist bis jetzt jedenfalls
keine erkenntnis da dass innerhalb
dieses zeitraums unbedingt eine
auffrischimpfung erfolgen muss aber das
sind ja auch noch keine abschließenden
erkenntnisse das wird weiter begleitet
und sich angeschaut und in dem moment wo
die erkenntnisse hätten und haben werden
wir natürlich dann noch entsprechendes
vorbereiten die mengen wie sie an dem
vertrag bei pfizer sehen für 2022 23 die
produktionskapazitäten jedenfalls
sichern wir jetzt schon übrigens ja auch
mit vertragsgestaltungen auch das ist ja
beschrieben worden der den noch mal ein
ganzes grad verbindlicher sind was
zeitpunkt und mögliche vertragsstrafen
angeht als die aktuell wieder auch immer
zum vorziehen von astra zenica halten
sie das wieder minister auch für
sinnvoll fielen durch die früheren
zweite impfung bei austral jetzt nicht
nötige erstimpfung sinkt der impfschutz
nicht von astra durch das vorziehen
du bist das wiederum nicht gefährlich
für die mutanten im herbst also
rechtfertigen aus ihrer sicht diese
nachteile das genommen ein paar wenige
früher den urlaub fahren können und
ersparen
wieder hat er gerade eindrücklich immer
gesagt die zahlen müssen massiv runter
immer noch haben sie ja im grunde auch
gesagt warum unterstützen sie eigentlich
nicht die rk ii strategie namens control
profit das habe ich nicht verstanden
also zu der frage astrazeneca haben
minister sparen und ich werde dieselbe
ansicht wir wissen dass je länger der
zeitraum der zweite impfung ist desto
besser ist der schutz und also ich jetzt
mal ich persönlich bin ja auch mit astra
weniger geimpft und natürlich werde ich
mich nach zwölf wochen erst impfen
lassen aber das ist ja gerade dieser
aspekt der jetzt eben entschieden werden
muss mich fragen sehr viele menschen
genau aus dem grund die herr minister
sparen auch genannt hatte wollen in
urlaub fahren und ich sage den menschen
dann eben das ist die situation der
impfschutz ist eben dann nicht so hoch
und das ist ja dann eben diese
aufgeklärte entscheidung die man
zusammen mit dem arzt dann trifft also
ich werde mich erst nach zwölf wochen
impfen lassen das ist für mich klar aber
wie gesagt das sind eben die überlegung
die wir in unserem staat den einzelnen
person überlassen die zulassung gibt das
her
der junge noch nicht beantwortet die
diskussion hatten wir ja auch schon
letzte woche und das
robert-koch-institut der professor
fehler und ich teilen den strategischen
ansatz kugel 19 den timings schon seit
14 monaten
wie auch die mehrheit des deutschen
bundestages und die bundesregierung und
nach meinem eindruck auch die mehrheit
der deutschen bevölkerung dass es darum
geht diese pandemie unter kontrolle zu
bringen control cobit heißt er am ende
tatsächlich das infektionsgeschehen zu
kontrollieren unter kontrolle zu haben
keinen diffuses kein dynamisches keines
was man irgendwie nicht mehr
nachvollziehen kann oder eine
größenordnung die uns in probleme
bringen zu haben dass das robert koch
institut wissenschaftlich hergeleitet
auf basis von studien von erkenntnissen
aus den letzten monaten konkrete
maßnahmen und übrigens nicht nur
maßnahmen sondern vor allem auch
studienlage präsentiert mit der studie
die mit control co wird immer zitieren
ist gut richtig und auch ausdrücklich
aufgabe hat das robert koch instituts
und gleichzeitig ist es aufgabe von
politik daraus dann tatsächlich im bund
länder und in der gesellschaftlichen
debatte im verbund daneben zu konkreten
entscheidungen zu kommen und diese
konkreten entscheidungen vor allem
nämlich instanz und wir wissen jetzt
einen unterschied zu manchen
nachbarländern nicht wenige
nachbarländer machen gerade datums
getragenes öffnen
also da wird ein datum genannt zudem
eine öffnung schritt passiert
wir machen incidence getragen ist oder
gestütztes oder basiertes öffnen
beziehungsweise zur rücknahme von
lockerungen und dass der ansatz über die
inzidenz geht und das ist auch incident
schritte unter 100 gibt ist zwischen
bund und ländern auch mehr oder weniger
seit über einem jahr ja unstrittig
wir haben doch übrigens die
ministerpräsidenten beschluss vom
dritten märz in dem für die frage was
ist wenn man unter 100 kommt auch
schritte vorgesehen sind
die übrigens von der grund logik her gar
nicht so weit abweichen
in einzelnen parametern tun sie das aber
das ist der unterschied im zweifel
wenn sich ihr nachvollziehbarer weise
auch immer wieder herausarbeiten
zwischen zum einen wissenschaftlicher
empfehlungen und dem was wir dann
tatsächlich in einem politisch
gesellschaftlichen abwägungsprozess zu
einer entscheidung bringen die strategie
ist und bleibt aber die gleiche
kontrolle über diese pandemie nachfrage
also ich glaube ihre strategie von einer
kontrolle der pandemie hat sehr wenig
mit der von villa und des fas zu tun das
wird ja immer wieder von einer wieder
und demokratie betont schuld ist zu 90
prozent die no go it strategie damit
haben sie nie zu tun haben wollen und
ich habe sich gefragt warum warum sie
control pro wird nicht unterstützen
ihr erkennt er sagt dass ich habe ja ich
habe die antwort gegeben
frisch dann hätte die stadt gerne doch
noch mal nach den intervallen
astrazeneca fragen
ich frage mich ob das vakzin wirklich
attraktiver macht bei dem man jetzt den
eindruck hat dass wird angepasst an die
urlaubspläne der deutschen
möglicherweise auch zu lasten der
sicherheit dieses wachstums oder der
wirksamkeit des taxis und wenn sie dass
beide so klar sagen dass das eigentlich
nichts gutes ist ist es denn dann
überhaupt politisch opportun dass man
eine solche offerte gemacht hat wenn man
weiß dass es möglicherweise denen das
impfen nicht nutzt eine frage an sie und
wenn ich noch darf eine an professor
villa
ich würde ganz gerne ein bisschen wissen
wie sich die mutation entwicklung in den
letzten wochen oder tagen gezeigt hat
ein brasilianisches virus in mecklenburg
vorpommern
wie ist die entwicklung da macht ihnen
das sorgen oder ist dass irgendwas was
beginn sinkenden zahlen ist nicht mehr
so sehr in ihrem fokus steht also zuerst
immer und dann bitte ich möchte ich
einfach nur für werben mehr kann ich
jetzt hier nicht machen aber nicht nutzt
trifft nur wirklich nicht den
sachverhalt schon die erstimpfung nutzt
enorm
wer professor wähler gerade dargestellt
hat und wir uns die studienlage zeigt
sie macht schon einen entscheidenden
unterschied
vor allem in den ersten wochen und das
ist ja dass wir die zulassung studien
zeigen das ist ja der entscheidende teil
wo wir die erkenntnisse her haben sie
lange nach einer erst impfungen das gilt
bei allen impfstoffen die zwei impfungen
brauchen wie lange welche wirkung anhält
wenn sie sich abschwächt ab wann es sinn
macht zu einer zweitimpfung zu kommen
dazu gibt's studienlage und jede
erstimpfung nutzt macht einen
unterschied schützt und jede zweite
impfung schützt dann als
auffrischimpfung noch zusätzlich und
mehr und vor allem stellt den schutz auf
den längeren zeitraum sicher und dann
hat sich bei astra zenica im ablauf
übrigens nach einiger zeit gezeigt dass
die wirksamkeit noch etwas höher ist was
er erst mal per se vielleicht nicht
sozusagen immer nahe liegend ist wenn
der abstand etwas länger es ist die
wirksamkeit etwas höher
das heißt nicht dass bei kürzerem
abstand kein schutz besteht also ist mir
echt sehr sehr wichtig dass du den
eindruck bitte jetzt auch nicht zu
vermitteln
das gegenteil ist der fall jede impfung
die zugelassen ist schützt schon nach
der ersten von trotzdem bleibe ich bei
einem punkt in dieser phase der pandemie
haben wir ein hohes interesse daran dass
möglichst viele menschen sich impfen
lassen
erst impfen und zweikämpfen und dass sie
das in verantwortungsvolle
entscheidungen für sich und mit ihrem
arzt entsprechend entscheiden ob
abklären
aber ich kann ja noch und ich wissen sie
wie sagte volker kauder immer zurecht
politik beginnt mit dem betrachten der
wirklichkeit und ich habe einfach
wahrgenommen was die letzten ein zwei
wochen passiert ist
das hat sich eine lage verändert und
diese debatte hat sich an jedem
küchentisch verändert und ich tippe auch
in den meisten redaktionsstuben mit der
entscheidung das vollständig geimpft an
bestimmten stellen anders eingeschränkt
sind zb oder keine test erfordernisse
mehr haben hat sich die diskussion
verändert und jetzt kann man sagen dass
nimmt politik nicht wahr
und wenn dann die astrazeneca dosen im
zweifel also wir haben sehr gesehen im
verhalten der
letzten zwei wochen dann in eine
geringere akzeptanz kommen und zwar
nicht weil sie schlechter sind sondern
wir alle sich nur noch mit der frage von
zwölf wochen abstand beschäftigen und
sonst mit gar nichts mehr
dann finde ich das in dieser phase der
pandemie nicht gut
wir brauchen viele die impfstoffe die da
sind und wir haben allein nächste woche
eine millionen astrazeneca dosen
verfügbar
wir brauchen viele die impfdosen die da
sind auch verhilft haben möchten und
dafür spielen ganz lebenspraktische
erwägungen für jeden ich tippe auch in
vielen redaktionsstuben eine rolle
herfried oder lila person noch ein danke
für die frage also nochmal prinzipiell
nur weil vielleicht medien mal temporär
weniger oder mehr interesse an einen
oder dem anderen sachverhalten der
panini haben das interessiert uns
natürlich nicht jetzt interessieren uns
kontinuierlich für alle fragen die wir
bearbeiten weil der pandemie und das
sehen sie auch in unserem situations
berichten die wir täglich publizieren
wurden die ganzen fakten immer drin
stehen also das geschehen betrachten wir
nach wie vor sehr intensiv wir haben ja
das deutsche elektronische sequenz
hauptspiels desch das ist eine extrem
gute innovation die uns auch für
zukünftige reger portal bietet wo wir
auch bei anderen erregern eine tolle
balance machen können wir haben jetzt
ich habe die zahl nicht mehr kopf ich
habe weit über 100.000 sequenzen wir
kriegen also kontinuierlich immer
sequenzen die sehr zeitnah automatisiert
ausgewertet würden und wir sehen zum
glück momentan immer noch die situation
dass wirklich weit über 90 prozent ist
dafür vor dieser b 11 7 ich sage zum
glück weil wir ja von der variante die
zunächst in südafrika entdeckt wurde
wissen dass sie den erfolg etwas unter
läuft also auch da wirkt die impfungen
aber nicht mehr so gut
und diese ganzen varianten auf konzern
wie wir sie nennen das sind ja drei
momentan die nach wie vor allem sehr
sehr niedrigen niveau einzelfälle
und das ist
gute entwicklung was auch noch uns
optimistisch stimmt ist dass in den
meisten varianten die wir sehen weil es
gibt ja natürlich tausende von varianten
die wir mit unseren methoden dadurch
dass weltweit die ganzen sequenzen
ausgetauscht werden automatisiert
untersucht werden können es gibt immer
wieder dieselbe mutation eigentlich also
das heißt wir sind eigentlich
optimistisch dass nicht plötzlich eine
ganz biologisch ganz andere variante
kommt die vielleicht das immunsystem
sehr stark unterläuft insofern ganz ganz
positiv gestimmt auch diese variante die
ihnen in indien beschrieben wurde die
haben wir auch inzwischen ab und zu
gesehen wir sehen aber momentan keine
großen clusterbildung das heißt also
dass die sich gezielt ausbreitet wir
verfolgen das und was wir getan haben
ist wir haben ja manche regeln etwas
verschärft in den letzten monaten gerade
um die b17 variante weil die ja eine
höhere viruslast hat das heißt die
menschen schreiben wie wir es aus noch
etwas länger da haben wir dann die
quarantäne verlängert und so weiter und
das wird ja auch durchgehalten
von den gesundheitsämtern und den ärzten
also momentan um es kurz
zusammenzufassen gibt es kein signal was
uns mehr beunruhigen würde ja momentan
ist das so und wir haben das
kontinuierlich im blick und werden das
auch so lange diese pandemie mit uns
hier unseren alltag bestimmt und auch
darüber hinaus über das wäre nur die
sequenzen immer noch analysieren wir
sind übrigens vom mittelfeld wo wir
waren im dezember beim genom
sequenzieren mittlerweile der top 5 mit
dabei israel dänemark vereinigtes
königreich traditionell aber sie sehen
problem erkannt im dezember wir haben
gemeinsam gehandelt und jetzt haben wir
zumindest mal in die spitzenliga beim
genom sequenzieren dann noch aufgeholt
hercog fried eine frage an den
gesundheitsminister
da sparen wir haben erfahren dass der
amerikanischen technologieriese ibm
angeblich den zuschlag erhalten hat zur
entwicklung eines nachweis zwei fragen
dazu
warum hat zum beispiel die viel kleinere
deutsche gesellschaft zur förderung von
im medizin den zuschlag eben nicht
erhalten obwohl ich schon seit jahren an
so einem
nachweis arbeiten und die zweite frage
ibm hat ihnen zuschaut angeblich vor
zwei monaten erhalten wie weit ist es
die entwicklung geht ihnen also ich bin
jetzt etwas überrascht dass sie sagen
sie haben erfahren und angeblich wir
haben das ja öffentlich gemacht den
zuschlag
der ist auch berichtet worden der ist
aber auch öffentlich zu machen da sind
wir nach vergaberecht zu verpflichtet
insofern ist das jetzt nichts nichts
nichts neues wir haben nach einer corona
kabinettsentscheidung 1
ich habe jetzt den fachbegriff nicht
aber ein entsprechend eingeschränktes
vergabeverfahren dass es möglich ist
unter pandemie bedingungen in
zeitknappheit gemacht es gab mehrere
angebote es gab eine angebots matrix die
dann ausgewertet worden ist wie man das
macht und der zuschlag in der matrix und
zusammenhängt mit dem preis ist dann
entsprechend an ein konsortium das
übrigens auch deutsche beteiligte hat
mit ibm im lied dann vergeben worden
dieser pass sozusagen als startpunkt den
gibt es schon ein ein unternehmen das
beteiligt ist machte schon in altötting
da gibt es ja tatsächlich schon einen
digitalen pass das ist das unternehmen
das zum beispiel bestandteil dieses
konsortiums also am ende ist es eine
klassische vergabeentscheidung gewesen
aber keine geheime
und wie weit ist der stand also der
stand der entschuldigung wir haben ja
gesagt und halten weiter noch an diesem
zeitplan fest ein zweites zweite hälfte
des zweiten quartals die beginnt
herfried dann herr reitschuster dann
haben wir noch drei fragen habe ich im
saal hier montiert ich werde keine
zweite runde hier mehr machen können
weil er noch fragen vom außen dran sind
ich weiß nicht ob alle dran kommen und
sagte ihnen die außen sind ich glaube
dass einige von den fragen die da
formuliert wurden jetzt auch schon
beantwortet und machen wir weiter
herfried bitte
ich muss nochmal eine nachfrage zuerst
weniger und zwar es wird ja so sein wenn
die fristen zwischen erst der zweite
punkt verkürzen dass wir dann gerade mit
blick auf die urlaubszeit werden sich
die termine fallen und zusammenschieben
wie so eine ziehharmonika und alle in
diese wochen vor beginn der sommerferien
dann fallen für die zweite impfungen ist
denn gewährleistet dass dann auch
ausreichend impfstoff zur verfügung
steht ich habe vorher mit einem nur
gehört dass hier in berlin schon nötig
gibt und man hier nicht mehr
nachbestellen kann und welche
auswirkungen hat das dann auf die
fortsetzung der kampagne was die
erstimpfung angeht also zuerst einmal
generell zuerst um zweite impfung wir
kommen jetzt tatsächlich und das sieht
man ja daran dass wir die letzten drei
vier tage auch rekordzahlen hatten bei
den zweit impfungen in eine phase mit
relativ vielen zweitimpfung warum weil
einfach vor sechs acht zehn wochen
insgesamt die mengen für die erste
impfung stark angestiegen sind als die
kampagne mehr an fahrt gewinnen konnte
wegen der lieferung jetzt ist zeitablauf
sozusagen für die zweite impfung jetzt
gibt es eine phase im mai relativ ja
eigentlich ziemlich im mai wo es sehr
viele zweite impfung gibt und relativ
viel weniger erstimpfungen und dann
werden wir im juni werden ja die
lieferung noch einmal deutlich weiter
anziehen dann das auch wieder mit mehr
erstimpfung verknüpfen können bei
astrazeneca ist es so dass ihr generell
die länder nur noch zwei impfungen
vornehmen weil die astrazeneca impfdosen
ansonsten insgesamt in die ärztliche
niedergelassene versorgung gehen in die
arztpraxen so ist es vereinbart in die
impfzentren geht
der impfstoff von biontech und der von
moderner jetzt sozusagen dauerhaft für
erst und zweitwohnungen dauerhaft für
die nächsten wochen monate so lange wir
in dieser staatlichen impfkampagne sind
und bei astrazeneca finden in den
impfzentren im grunde nur noch zwei
impfungen statt
meine eigenen eltern haben auch dass
zwölf wochen hinter wal und werden es
auch nach eigener entscheidung
beibehalten ich bin auch sehr sicher
dass viele das tun werden also ich
glaube dass es ist am ende die frage wie
gesagt einfach der entscheidung im
rahmen der zulassung von arzt und zu
impfenden aber wenn berlin bedarf hat
für zwei impfungen ein astra zenica
haben wir den bis jetzt immer gedeckt
und den werden wir auch in zukunft
weiter denkt bereits schuster herr
professor doktor villa sie sagten ab 80
prozent durch impfung kann man die
maßnahmen zurückfahren gleichzeitig
sagte herr sparen
es ist noch unklar wie lange die impfung
wirkt wann man wieder impfen muss gibt
es dann widerspruch ist da die gefahr
einer wellenbewegung und anhand sparen
noch eine frage die nächtlichen
ausgangssperre hat ihr ministerium
begründet mit wissenschaftlichen studien
und auch auf der seite werden
wissenschaftliche studien an geführt die
aber gar keine sind die sind alle drei
nicht peer reviewed also nicht überprüft
da sagen wissenschaftler derzeit
unseriös die als studien zu bezeichnen
wenn sie das noch klären könnten dann
kennen ja danke tschüss dafür diese
frage das ist kein widerspruch
weil wir ja weltweit impfen und
natürlich weltweit viele studien
durchgeführt werden und diese nie werden
uns zeigen wann eine
auffrischungsimpfung sein wird und dann
wird die entsprechend nachgeholt das
heißt also dieses impfangebot von dem
wir das ja wirklich enorm inzwischen ist
und auch weiter wächst das wird ja noch
monate und jahre lang ja auch da sein
also die impfstoffe werden weiter
verfügbar sein und dann werden die
menschen geimpft das impfangebot wird
ihn wieder gemacht wenn wir von der
studienlage her wissen wenn das
notwendig ist
das werden wir anhand von studien aber
sehen können momentan ist da das wissen
noch nicht in dem maße vorhanden
wir werden noch öfter impfen müssen das
ist klar aber die zeitabstände können
wir ihnen einfach noch nicht sagen
vedder nochmal grundsätzlich jetzt zu
den phasen die vor uns liegen wir sind
ja jetzt wie merken dass er jetzt das so
phasen muss so verschiedene spannungs
situationen gibt jetzt die spannungs
situation geimpfte ungeimpfte das ist
eine spannung situation glaube ich
wirklich in jeder familie in jedem
freundeskreis in jedem bekanntenkreis in
der frage wie die die situation ist es
jetzt eine situation für einige wochen
dass wir tatsächlich eben der will auch
ein impfangebot werden gemacht haben
können aber das ist eine spannung die
wir aushalten muss zweite spannung
situation wird entstehen und die
entsteht jetzt auch schon gerade
insbesondere auch in den regionen wohnen
deutlichen ja wir haben ja regionen mit
1 events unter 50 sogar im norden der
republik in vielen in einigen
landkreisen aber so eine situation wo
wir die balance zwischen lockern und
noch notwendigen schutzmaßnahmen gut
finden müssen weil es durchaus länder
auf der welt gibt die ja schon gezeigt
denn wir haben ja beispiele gilt
übrigens auch für ausgangs beschränkung
werden wir beispiel auf der welt was
passiert passieren kann wenn sie trotz
auch schon relativ vor impfquote soviel
lockern kann es ihnen passieren dass da
noch mal richtige wellen entstehen
in einem land wie china sehen war es
gerade akut aber auch in israel hat man
das durchaus gesehen in dem abläufen
das ist aus meiner sicht diese balance
sehr sehr wichtig auch sozusagen
zuversicht perspektive zu geben
auch durchaus unter 100 zu zeigen dass
das jetzt eine andere situation ist dass
man etwa außenbereiche das finde ich
einfach sehr wichtig den fokus da vor
allem zu haben jetzt bei den ersten
eröffnungs schritten test gestützt
auch öffnen kann aber es heißt eben noch
nicht auch nicht wenn wir 50 prozent
jeden zweiten geimpft haben werden dass
man gleich alles wieder so haben kann
wie vor der pandemie das wird noch eine
phase in brauchen wo man beispielsweise
in bereichen wo menschen eng beieinander
sind weiterhin etwa masken regeln und
anderes brauchen wird und trotzdem
werden wir sehen schon bei 50 60 prozent
durch impfungen effekten deutlichen wir
sehen jetzt schon einen effekt bei den
über 70-jährigen wieder insgesamt
incident die krankheitslast ist jetzt so
ein wort aber schwere und schwerste
verläufe todesfall zahlen zurückgehen
und trotzdem können wir jetzt deswegen
ja nicht sagen wir geben alle
schutzmaßnahmen auf eben ein zu großer
teil noch nicht
geimpft und geschützt ist und wenn wir
50 prozent geimpft haben werden das ist
ja absehbar
dann werden wir es noch deutlicher sehen
und trotzdem können wir dann nicht sagen
aber jetzt alle maßnahmen gleich fallen
lassen weil immer noch ein zu großer
teil nicht geschützt ist und ein risiko
für sich hat aber auch fürs
gesundheitssystem in der überlastung
diese phasen gut abzustimmen
das ist es ist politisch herausfordernd
wird es werden aber das ist es natürlich
auch einfach gesellschaftlich und in
jeder gemeinschaft vor ort und eine
zeitlang den geimpften zu sagen aber
bitte weiterhin etwa masken und
abstandsregeln eine zeitlang einhalten
zum schutz von uns allen dass das wird
natürlich immer schwerer werden aber ich
finde wir haben jetzt 14 monate ziemlich
gut gemeinsam durch diese pandemie
geschafft wir werden jetzt auch in
diesem weg raus der auch nicht
spannungsfrei ist da bin ich sehr
zuversichtlich auch das noch gemeinsam
schaffen aber es wird noch manche nicht
nur wissenschaftlich getriggert sondern
vor allem in gesellschaftlichen
abwägungs diskussion gefundene
kompromiss linie brauchen
ich habe die frage zu den die habe ich
in die also wir haben die frage was sie
als wissenschaftlichen studien standard
akzeptieren oder nicht ist im übrigen ja
auch eine diskussion über seit 14
monaten haben wo tatsächlich erste
studienergebnisse ja auch schon
veröffentlicht werden früher als man das
sonst die diskussion hatten wir ja auch
in anderen aspekten auch in der
wissenschaft als sonst aber es gibt eben
evidenz und studien dazu ob die ihnen
ausreichend oder anderen ausreichend
wissenschaftlich belegt sind und nicht
aber die kann man natürlich immer
streiten ob es gibt auch meistens ja
dann irgendwie wieder eine erkenntnis
die durch einen etwas anderen ansatz
wider was relativieren das hat 1 bleibt
aber doch das haben wir immer gesagt die
nächtliche ausgangsbedingungen hat er
nicht zum hauptziel das nachts um elf
jemand nicht alleine mit dem
es geht sowieso aber mit dem hund gassi
gehen können soll sondern es geht darum
insgesamt mobilität und kontakte zu
reduzieren das ist das ziel
und da sind ausgangs beschränkungen
nicht das alleinige mittel aber ein
wichtiges ergänzendes mittel und nahezu
alle länder auf der welt wie die dritte
welle unter kontrolle gebracht haben
haben auch zu diesem mittel gegriffen
und hatten damit erfolg
jetzt muss das noch nicht per se eine
kausalität sein kann auch eine
korrelation sein aber es ist zumindest
auch evidenz soll ich jetzt drei fragen
noch im saal und ich frage mal sind das
punkte die noch nicht angesprochen sind
dann stellen sie sie fangen wir bei ihm
ja willkommen zurück und einen schönen
guten tag zum zdf heute live wer waren
gerade bei der pressekonferenz live aus
berlin mit bundesgesundheitsminister
sparen und lka-präsident wieder zur
aktuellen lage
kroner lage mit den aktuellen zahlen und
natürlich auch zu den geplanten
lockerungen
beide zeigten sich vorsichtig
optimistisch die zahlen sinken leicht
seit ende april
der bundesweite incidents wert liegt
heute bei 126 und ersparen meinte dass
die dritte welle scheint gebrochen die
notbremse hätte dazu geführt lassen wir
uns die zahlen und auch dieses thema
gleich einordnen von unserem
gesprächspartner und experten thorsten
lehr von der uni des saarlandes
er ist professor für klinische pharmazie
wenn ihr fragen habt kommentare
loswerden wollt dann natürlich immer in
die vorher vorgesehen den
kommentarspalten oder an zdf heute
strich live at zdf.de so herr thorsten
leer einen schönen guten tag schön dass
sie da sind
hallo hallo ich ja sie haben es
vielleicht mitbekommen ersparen und
wähler zeigten sich ja sehr optimistisch
die zahlen sinken leicht seit ende april
wie optimistisch sind sie
ja also ich würde sagen diesen
vorsichtigen optimismus den theilig ich
denke die beiden herren hat das
teilweise sehr gut zusammengefasst wir
haben auf jeden fall jetzt rückläufig
inzidenz sein
ich bin auch der meinung dass die bundes
notbremse und aktionen sehr wichtigen
teil beigetragen haben wir haben jetzt
seit ende april wirklich fallende zahlen
die jeden tag die inzidenz noch ungefähr
fünf teilweise zehn punkte senkt also
das sind sehr positive entwicklungen und
wenn es so weitergeht denke ich sind wir
auf dem richtigen wege
sie haben auch die notbremse sind jetzt
gerade schon angesprochen
die gilt ja eigentlich erst jetzt seit
naja sagen wir mal knapp zwei wochen
wir haben ja einen kommentar von bed
style von youtube der meint dass das
infektionsgeschehen ja eigentlich immer
erst die lage in zwei wochen zeigt also
dass er eigentlich meinen dass die
zahlen schon vor der notbremse gesunken
sein beziehungsweise mesut da die viren
auf facebook schreibt dass die
fallzahlen zurückgehen läge ja nicht an
der politik sondern an der jahreszeit
was meinen sie dazu ja also erst mal der
punkt dass diese zahlen eigentlich schon
voll zurück gegangen bin sind dem stimme
ich erstmal zu wir haben ja eigentlich
auch gesehen dass als die diskussion um
die bundes notbremse kam
viele bundesländer sich schon mal bei
der ja sozusagen schon mal selber ran
genommen haben und die notbremse die er
vorher ende ähnlichen form existierte
einfach mal durchgezogen haben hamburg
hat das sehr vorbildlich vorgemacht und
dementsprechend es ist vieles von dem
was wir sehen auch schon durch maßnahmen
die kurz vorher getroffen wurden jetzt
sichtbar das zweite was wir auch sagen
müssen wir haben auch natürlich diesen
psychologischen effekt bei der
bevölkerung das heißt immer wenn wir
über maßnahmen diskutieren wenn wir
schwierige situationen haben sehen wir
dass die maßnahmen oft schon eigentlich
greifen bevor sie eigentlich offiziell
implementiert werden das heißt die
bevölkerung nimmt sich einfach in diesen
risikoreichen situationen entsprechend
zurück und die infektion werden schon
automatisch ein bisschen zurückgefahren
das heißt dass sie dieser wahn
mechanismus funktioniert und das ist
erst mal ganz gut so der zweite zweite
frage ging einrichtungen arm was macht
der sommer was macht das wetter das ist
sicherlich ein wichtiger faktor wir
sehen diese sogenannte saisonalität bei
vielen eigentlich bei allen coronaviren
die existieren
beim saas koch 2 virus wird das auch
zu sein es wird einen positiven einfluss
haben es gibt einige die das halbmetall
doch darauf pochen dass das der einzige
effekt ist ich glaube und viele andere
glauben auch dass jeder effekt zwar
vorhanden ist dass wir vielleicht noch
mit 10 20 prozentige reduktion auf eine
mehrwert sehen durch die saisonalität
also das wetter aber eine vollständige
elimination dieses virus allein durch
das wetter um das sehe ich nicht
sie haben ja mit ihrem team zusammen
eine art mit 19 simulator entwickelt
damit können sie das ja
infektionsgeschehen berechnen was
glauben sie denn wie es jetzt
weitergehen wird wenn man die zahlen
betrachtet ja also wenn es jetzt so
weitergeht wie es momentan ist und das
muss man ja mal sagen es ist immer bei
diesen vorhersagen und produktion muss
man immer sagen das ist ein status quo
wie es sich jetzt momentan abzeichnen
wenn wir das weiter fortsetzen dann
würden jetzt noch weiter fallende zahlen
sehen
wir würden dann eigentlich erwarten dass
wir zumindest deutschlandweit unter die
grenze von 50 eine inzidenz von 50
ungefähr im juni die durchstoßen werden
wahrscheinlich in der ersten junihälfte
wir müssen aber auch da wieder ein
zweiter faktor sehen wir werden
sicherlich erleben dass auch wenn die
instanzen unter 100 fallen das wieder
lockerung stattfinden werden das heißt
also dass vielleicht dieses verhalten
ein bisschen abgebremst wird diese
sinkende verhalten und das dürfen wir
einfach in dieser berechnung nicht
vergessen das lässt sich ein bisschen
schwer wirklich predigt ihren weil wir
nicht genau wissen welche maßnahmen die
politik dann entsprechend durch
durchsetzen wird oder wieder lockern
wird und auf der anderen seite sehen wir
das was wir gerade schon besprochen
haben bei der bevölkerung in
risikoreichen situationen das heißt
wenigen sätzen hoch sind
das sehen wir gerade am anderen ende der
incidence kette auch das heißt sinken
also die inzidenz selber darunter werden
wird die bevölkerung einfach etwas ja
ich will nicht sagen nachlässig aber
vielleicht fahrlässiger oder etwas nach
nachsichtiger was die maßnahmen angeht
das heißt da wären dann teilweise auch
wieder mehr kontakte vielleicht begangen
weil man sich in der sicheren situation
befindet also da müssen wir schauen dass
wir das noch entsprechend durchhalten
damit wir die instanzen auch wieder jahr
ordentlich wenn einen niedrigeren
bereich
unterbringen können bis die impfung dann
letztendlich wirklich ausreichend wirken
jetzt hat ja herr sparen auch noch mal
ja die länder kritisiert die jetzt sehr
vorschnell gelockert haben zum beispiel
bayern mit mit dass man zum beispiel
jetzt zu pfingsten auch dort schon
urlaub machen kann wie gesagt sie haben
ja diese berechnungen können sie daran
schon irgendwie erkennen ob die
maßnahmen jetzt wirklich greifen und vor
allen dingen auch die geimpften ob die
ob das jetzt überhaupt auch dazu
beigetragen hat dass die zahlen gesunken
sind oder sind es doch nur die
abstandsregeln hygienemaßnahmen etc
ja also wir sind momentan eine mischung
aus beiden maßen haben wir sehen den
bildschirm aus den impfungen wir sie
natürlich eine mischung aus den
maßnahmen die ergriffen wurden durch die
notbremse sah ist jetzt die bundes
notbremse die davor geschaltete
notbremse
die impfungen und das hat er wieder
folgende ich auch schon jetzt gut
gesagte drückt eigentlich jetzt den
diesen diese nährwert schon mal so um
einige prozent runter hatte ja gesagt
wenn wir die impfung rausrechnen würden
hätten wir ungefähr wert von 1,2
jetzt haben wir ungefähr so um die 0,9
das heißt also das hilft schon mal dass
wir vom wachstum in mehr oder weniger
jetzt eine niedrigere incidents lage
kommen und infektions lager das heißt es
hilft uns schon mal aber die maßnahmen
brauchen wir trotzdem noch weil sonst
werden wir alles wieder lockern würden
hätten wir wieder eher werte selbst mit
der impfung jetzt die weit über 1 liegen
würden in die zu einem sehr schnellen
anstieg führen das heißt die impfung die
wir bis jetzt haben die sind erst mal
noch nicht ausreichend diese 30 prozent
erste impfung knapp zehn prozent 2
dämpfen
die sind zwar schon sehr schön und
sichtbar eben auf den intensivstationen
und teilweise eben auch in den
bevölkerungsgruppen die schon sehr gut
durch 15 0 das heißt die älteren dort
sehen wir dass die inzidenz angenehm
niedrig sind aber wir sehen dann
entsprechend die verschiebung der
instanzen halt jetzt zu den jüngeren und
da haben wir noch einen ganz großen pool
an leuten die eben noch nicht geimpft
sind und das wird auch noch ein bisschen
dauern bis die alle durch 15 trotz der
hohen geschwindigkeit also das heißt
hier ist noch ein bisschen vorsicht
geboten und ich war jetzt hier auch
wirklich vor zu früher lockerung und zu
früher freude da sind jetzt hier auf der
zielgeraden wir sollten jetzt wirklich
aufpassen dass wir uns jetzt hier auf
dieser zielgeraden wirklich nicht
verstolpern
und irgendwie noch das bein brechen und
uns noch mal mächtig weh tun bevor würde
ich diese ziel gelaufen
wir haben also sie kritisieren also zu
sagen auch die ja vorstellen lockerungen
beziehungsweise raten da auch er zur
vorsicht wie auch der professor wieder
und sparen wir haben hier noch eine
frage von lfk von aus youtube team fragt
wie zurückhaltend müsste man denn wenn
jetzt die zahlen natürlich sinken man
bei schul und kita öffnungen jetzt
wieder sein
das war ja auch so ein hin und her sag
jetzt mal ja die schulen kitas öffnungen
sind natürlich so ein
das ist natürlich so eine so eine
pandora kiste die man ja nie aufnahmen
möchte weil zum einen möchten wir die
bildung gewährleisten und das ist ja
auch ganz wichtig für die schülerinnen
und schüler und auch die
kindergartenkinder und natürlich auch
damit die eltern letztendlich ihrer
tätigkeit nachgehen können auf der
anderen seite sehen wir natürlich schon
sehr hohe inzidenz und vor allem in
diesen bereichen das dürfen wir nicht
vergessen
die inzidenz dort sind wirklich
überproportional hoch das heißt
infektionen finden dort statt und jetzt
durch vor allem diese flächen deckende
testung die wir dort natürlich
durchführen finden wir diese umfelder
auch das heißt ich glaube die schule
sicherlich ein teil das das
infektionsgeschehen es das zeigen auch
die daten dass wenige schulen
geschlossen sind dass die zahlen
entsprechend runtergehen dass es
letztendlich eine tatsache also ich wäre
zum einen erst mal dafür wirklich auch
die schulen mit bedacht zu öffnen also
erst mal im wechsel unterricht erst mal
weiter fortzuführen und was aber ganz
wichtig ist dass wir eben uns eben auch
gedanken machen dass wir vor allem auch
die schülerinnen und schüler jetzt bei
den impfungen nicht vergessen und sie
nicht ans ende der im kette stellen
sondern es entsprechend nach oben auch
priorisieren die jugendlichen selbst ja
auch erwähnt sind ja auch ein ungenauer
faktor bzw dieses ganze problem weil
kinder und jugendliche natürlich auch
eine mobile gruppe sind so wie man das
so schön sagt sie haben ja da auch ein
spezielles pilotprojekt was sie gerne
vorstellen wollen
weil es ja auch gerade darum geht das
ist ja auch in der diskussion in den
letzten tagen ab wann jetzt kinder
ab 12 dämpft werden dürfen da fehlt ja
jetzt noch die entsprechende zulassung
vielleicht können sie kurz das projekt
erklären und was sie was das sozusagen
dann bringen wird ja genau also wir
haben uns dann ein projekt über lego
jetzt eben schauen wollen dass wir vor
allem schülerinnen schüler und junge
erwachsene letztendlich auch prioritär
versuchen wollen zu impfen in einem
projekt das wir gerade auch setzen was
aber noch nicht genehmigt ist
die idee ist halt dass dort schülerinnen
schüler berufsschüler auch studierende
aus einem gewissen landkreis in dem
pilotprojekt jetzt vorgesehen sein
sollen für impfungen wie gesagt es ist
leider noch nicht genehmigt da arbeiten
wir dran und wir wollen dann halt
entsprechend auch schauen was bringt das
denn eigentlich für die die inzidenz in
diesen gruppen und diese idee ist
natürlich auch dass in gewissen ping
pong effekt haben das heißt sie haben
natürlich die die kinder generation die
es jedoch die eltern überträgt und
andersrum
das heißt wir können relativ viel lernen
auch darüber welchen einfluss zum
beispiel infektion von den schülerinnen
und schülern auch auch die
elterngeneration haben in dem wir dann
dort wirklich sehr genau die instanzen
beobachten und analysieren
also das ist ein ziel was wir jetzt
durchführen wollen und ein projekt und
das soll jetzt endlich danach noch ein
psychologisch begleitet werden das heißt
dass wir auch noch einfach schauen was
ist mit der lebensqualität weil wir
sehen das natürlich schon auch aus
erzählungen und daraus ersten studien
dass dort vor allem auch die junge
generation sehr stark leidet und das ist
natürlich extrem nachvollziehbar warum
es ist sicherlich eine situation wo ich
dankbar bin dass ich nicht mehr ganz so
jung bin weil ich glaube das ist extrem
schwer für die jugend und die haben wir
total vernachlässigt in den letzten 14
monaten sie sprechen jetzt die
psychischen folgen an in dieser ganzen
pandemie zeit bei ihrem projekt geht es
ja auch darum was es für auswirkungen
hat wenn wir jetzt perspektivisch
gesehen wenn jetzt noch mehr pandemien
kommen sollten wovon ja einige experten
ihr auch ausgehen was es genau heißt
weil sie sagen dass man früher bei den
jüngeren altersgruppen ansetzen soll was
genau meinen sie damit und bedeutet das
so zu sagen dass man beispielsweise bei
impfungen auch er dann ins priorisierung
auch gleich die jungen mit denkt ja bei
der jetzigen priorisierung es ist ja so
dass wir vor allem die wollen rabl und
gruppen
erst geschützt haben das heißt also die
die besonders leiden besonders anfällig
sind für erkrankung wenn auch gesehen
dass das gut war und dass das auch die
sterblichkeit sehr stark gesenkt hat
dass auch die krankenhauseinweisungen
zurückgegangen sind die älteren
patientinnen und patienten laufen nicht
mehr so stark auf den intensivstationen
auch weil sie vorsätzlich geschützt sind
aber letztendlich wenn man mal bedenkt
was die mobilität angeht denn sicherlich
nicht die gruppe der über 80-jährigen
diejenigen immobil abends eben auf den
wiesen rumhängen und grillen das wäre
schön aber das tun sie in der regel
richter ist heißt die sind sowieso von
ihrer mobilität allein schon durch das
alter und vielleicht durch die
wohnsituation im alten und pflegeheim
deutlich eingeschränkter das heißt wer
viele kontakte hat das sind natürlich
die schülerinnen und schüler ganz
natürlich und das ist natürlich auch die
arbeitende bevölkerung das heißt
pandemisch betrachtet wäre es sicherlich
auch sinnvoll sich diesen gruppen von
der anderen seite zu nähern
letztendlich ist es aber immer eine
gewisse auch verteilungskampf denen wir
ja jetzt auch sehen und es wird auch
immer diskussionen geben warum impfte
jetzt vergleicht die schülerinnen und
schüler zuerst werden es vielleicht noch
den 50-jährigen asthmatiker gibt dennoch
keine impfung hat also ich glaube
vollständige gerechtigkeit wenn wir nie
schaffen das wird eine sehr schwierige
situation sein aber wir wollen halt eben
auch versuchen zu lernen in diesem
projekt was denn ermöglichen
wichtig ist vor allem dass wir in diesem
projekt jetzt auch eben keine impfstoffe
abzocken wollen von den priorisierung
gruppen sondern dort halt auch
zusätzlich impfstoffe bekommen
inzwischen ist es ja auch so dass herr
spahn ist er gestern auch schon
angekündigt hat dass die impfstoffe auch
zwischen 12 und 18 jährigen im sommer
dann freigegeben werden sollen sobald
sie verfügbar sind
das ist sicherlich gut und spielt ja
auch genau in die gleiche richtung unser
ziel von dem projekt ist es halt jetzt
das eben auch nochmal genauer
wissenschaftlich zu evaluieren weil wir
wissen nicht ob vielleicht im nächsten
jahr oder auch in ein paar jahren
vielleicht nochmal pandemien kommen und
dann müssen wir einfach viel mehr aus
dieser jetzigen wahrnehmen lernen um
dann zukünftig vielleicht auch
effizienter dieser maßnahmen steuern zu
können
sie warten jetzt noch auf grünes licht
so viel ich weiß um dann das projekt in
der stadt siegen durchführen zu können
vielen dank professor für ihre
einschätzung für ihre meinung und bis
zum nächsten mal
ja und auch zur im freien folge ins
priorisierung hat sich natürlich auch
das zdf- politbarometer beschäftigt wir
haben das kurz zusammengefasst jeder
überblick schon am wochenende könnte es
für vollständig geimpfte und genesene
heißen schluss mit den streng kontakt
beschränkungen schluss mit
ausgangssperre
schluss mit test licht vor dem shoppen
das findet breite unterstützung laut
zdf-politbarometer sagen 67 prozent
geimpft genesene und negativ getestete
wollten gleichgestellt werden und 59
prozent finden es dann auch richtig die
einschränkungen aufzuheben um die korona
maßnahmen besonders um die
ausgangssperren wurde viel gestritten
sie sind übertrieben finden 24 49
prozent sagen die maßnahmen sind gerade
richtig das sind 20 prozentpunkte mehr
als letzten monat 23 finden sie müssten
härter ausfallen
die impfkampagne in deutschland hat
deutlich an tempo gewonnen immer mehr
impfstoff steht zur verfügung
deshalb sollte jetzt die im freien folge
aufgehoben werden das unterstützen 70
prozent 28 prozent der befragten lehnen
das ab und so sehr sich das auch alle
wünschen eine mehrheit glaubt nicht dass
wir die krise ende des sommers im griff
haben ja wir sind jetzt zugeschaltet zu
unserem nächsten experten dr robert jung
aus schönebeck das ist bei magdeburg
schön dass sie da sind hallo
sie sind sie kommen gerade aus ihrer
sprechstunde wir wollen mit ihnen über
die mögliche aufhebung der ems
priorisierung reden und natürlich auch
über die aktuelle lage in den arztpraxen
vielleicht können sie kurz ihre praxis
vorstellen und ja wie viele menschen sie
bisher auch schon geimpft haben ja
wahrscheinlich kraft ein schreibfehler
mein name ist robin union und wir haben
eine praxis hier schönebeck im
salzlandkreis in sachsen anhalt außerdem
auch haus natürlich an der universität
in magdeburg tätig
und wir haben insgesamt seitdem die
impfkampagne in der hausarztpraxis
starten konnte ca 1000 patienten geimpft
wir haben allerdings auch vier standorte
und betreuen insgesamt so zwischen 7 und
8 tausend patienten insgesamt über die
vier standorte so dass das also noch
lange nicht alle patienten unserer
praxis sind wie wir dahin von konnten
was ist denn ihr größtes problem
momentan es wird ja auch die bürokratie
bemängelt aber was haben sie konkret
ja das größte problem lässt sich gar
nicht so unbedingt fassen es gibt viele
probleme eines was besonders vorne steht
ist die mangelnde planbarkeit also immer
wieder haben wir ja impfstoff bestellt
und der impfstoff wurde dann gekürzt
das traf sowohl für bayern als auch für
asthmatiker impfstoff das sind ja die
beiden impfstoffe die eine
hausarztpraxis und bisher bestellt
werden können und verhindert werden
können und immer wieder kommt es zu
kürzungen das ist auch nicht absehbar
das ist auch regional sehr
unterschiedlich und so können wir
natürlich sehr schlecht planen auch in
die zukunft wir planen jetzt quasi von
woche zu woche
wenn ein patient bei uns steht und sagt
ich möchte gerne eine impfung haben ich
bin drei in der priorität 3 und wir sind
aber noch nicht mit der 2 fertig dann
kann ich überhaupt einen termin und zwei
monaten gehen weil ich weiß dass ich
immer so und so filmstoff regel sondern
die impfstoff planbarkeit ist ein großes
problem ambulant vielleicht können sie
das auch kurz mal erläutern wie das
eigentlich vonstattengeht war ich glaube
viele menschen da draußen ist gar nicht
so klar wie kompliziert das eigentlich
ist die impfstoffe die impfdosen zu
erhalten wie wie läuft das ab weil sie
jetzt ja auch meinen dass das das ist
einfach zu wenig gibt ja also wir
dürfen immer impfstoff bestellen pro
arzt eine bestimmte menge von ihrem
impfstoff und kriegen dann dass es am
montag wo das einmal passieren muss und
kriegen dann am mittwoch eine meldung in
der regel von der apotheke das so und so
viel impfstoff dann tatsächlich von den
großhändlern zur verfügung gestellt
werden kann
und das ist eben oft nicht die menge die
wir bestellt haben und wie stark die
reduktion da stattfindet das wissen wir
vorher nicht und erst nachdem war eine
klare meldung haben und wissen was für
die kommende woche an impfstoff zur
verfügung steht
erst danach können wir natürlich planen
wir in der nächsten woche dran ist und
erst dann können wir auch die patienten
run telefonieren
die die in den entsprechenden kredit etz
gruppen sind jetzt hat herr spahn der
gesundheitsminister gestern verkündet
dass ab sofort die im freien folge für
den impfstoff astrazeneca aufgehoben
werden soll also unabhängig vom alter
von vorerkrankungen berufsgruppe bringt
ihnen das was ja das gibt wieder neue
probleme und ein also der astra sie
legal hatte da kann man schon mal so
sagen meinen sie was was was sind das
für neue probleme
astrazeneca hat ja im allgemeinen keinen
guten ruf unter der bevölkerung und wir
sind regelmäßig am diskutieren auch in
den hochaltrigen patientengruppen oder
das jahr auch tools zugelassen ist und
nachweislich die viel besprochene sinus
thrombose eben gar kein problem
darstellt zumindest kein relevantes und
jetzt die priorisierung aufzuheben nur
weil die dem stoff quasi keiner will ist
ja auch schön aber andererseits sage ich
mir auch in england haben sie da gar
keine differenzierung gemacht und
dialogen sie immer dass sie so fleißig
und schnell geimpft haben das ist auch
gut aber er hat da nicht nur gesagt dass
18 über die übungsgruppen frei ist jetzt
sondern auch dass der imf abstand
verkürzt werden kann und damit
haben wir natürlich wieder ein problem
denn wir kriegen sozusagen immer mehr
zwei impfungen in die hausarztpraxis wir
sind ja jetzt gerade mal knappe fünf
oder sechs wochen dabei also die zweite
impfung kommen jetzt in die arztpraxis
und umso früher die zweitimpfung ansteht
auch für astrazeneca um so weniger erst
irgendwann könnte man machen umso
weniger sozusagen gesamtschule ist da
und das sind sozusagen so urlaubs
impfungen und die möchten natürlich die
da haben weil er die vorteile die eben
erwähnten haben möchte aber damit bleibt
dann ja immer die impfung für die dann
weg sie haben es gerade wenn die
impfungen weg bleiben denn was sind denn
die kommentare oder das feedback was sie
vielleicht bekommt von älteren also 60
jährigen die sagen sie möchten den astra
zinniker nicht bekommen die nehmen ja
dann könnte man ja meinen den jüngeren
dann den die anderen impfstoffe weg das
kann man so sagen weil man es möchte
heraus
aber sowas gibt es natürlich immer
wieder wir haben patienten die so
verunsichert sind durch die
verbreiterung der dieser seltene
nebenwirkung in den medien dass sie
einfach kein gutes gefühl haben diesen
impfstoff zu bringen ich habe also und
auch meine kollegen und dem produkt
fusselig geredet über risiko nutzen und
auch die deutsche gesellschaft für
allgemein- und familienmedizin hat ein
wunderschönes blatt entworfen wo
sozusagen alltags risiken gegenüber
gestellt werden gegenüber die sieben -
venenthrombose und da fahren wir auch
auf unsere praxis laufen und ich muss
aber immer wieder feststellen dass ihre
sachliche argumente bei solchen
medikament nicht immer ausreichend
sondern es ist wenn ich mir jemand sitzt
nicht sozusagen behandeln lässt lässt
dann ist das auch immer vertrauenssache
auch image sache und wenn der impfstoff
kein gutes image hat und das hat er eben
im moment nicht ich hoffe sehr dass ich
das noch ändern dann wird immer
schwierig man muss kurz dazu sagen dass
wir mit ihnen per skype verbunden sind
und die leitungen ein wenig hakt wir
bitten dies zu entschuldigen
mit dieser technischen störung aber wir
schauen
wir schaffen das schon so weiter sie
haben es jetzt auch gerade nochmal
erwähnt hier gibt es auch einige
kommentare bezüglich des schlechten rufs
zu astrazeneca giaccherini bei youtube
schreibt bevor ich mir astrazeneca gebe
gebe ich mir das album von helene
fischer
also da ist natürlich auch immer die
frage und jemand sagt fragt hier noch
ohne anonym wer impft sich eigentlich
noch mit diesen aktien und jemand ganz
anderes schreibt wie sieht es denn
eigentlich aus mit dem impfstoff johnson
& johnson weil da ist ja der vorteil
dass man sich nur einmal impfen lassen
muss und nicht eine zweite impfung
braucht wie schätzen sie das ein
also zu den bedenken zu den fragen der
bedingung zu astrazeneca das spiegelt
der genau das wider was ich gerade
gesagt habe nichtsdestotrotz denke ich
dass das sind mit dem dass das ziel
sozusagen die die impfung voranzutreiben
durch die öffnung der priorisierung auch
erreicht wird denn es gibt immer noch
genug leute die sich eben doch auch von
argumenten überzeugen lassen und die
klar sehen dass der nutzen einer impfung
auch mit astrazeneca das risiko weit
überwiegt auch in den jüngeren
altersgruppen und wie gesagt gerade vor
dem hintergrund dass in england gar
nicht so hochgekocht ist und wie er sie
dafür loben denke ich ist das in deren
lebensrealität zum beispiel ganz gut
gelaufen und wir werden jetzt auch die
astra zenica versuchen zu bestellen und
für die unsere patienten anzubieten die
eben auch außerhalb der prägend sind und
die darauf folgende frage da ging es um
das man doch mal bitte was haben sie
gefragt schon da war doch der letzte
kommentar hat jetzt habe ich schnell
meinen sie zu johnson & johnson
ja genau auf ziemlich auch gut weil
genau da haben wir nämlich dieses
problem mit der zweite impfung nicht die
zweitimpfung blockieren sonst ja jetzt
quasi auch so ein bisschen unsere
kapazitäten weil wir brauchen ja nicht
nur impfstoff sondern wir brauchen auch
personal und das geht ja
monaten am stock war ja auch die testen
und andere sachen in der arztpraxis
ablaufen müssen und insofern auch mal
für die zweite impfung eben auch
ressourcen und dann wenn man sonst hätte
der song erzählt ja auch noch das wir
haben dazu sagen
wir haben hier auch noch eine frage von
sabine berlin bei facebook weil man ja
noch nicht lange fertig ist mit der impf
gruppe 2 inzwischen drängeln sich neben
diesen ja auch die leute der imw gruppe
3 nach vorne
es gibt ja auch manchmal schon ich weiß
nicht ob sie so etwas auch schon gehabt
haben dass die leute sie dann anrufen
und sagen bitte bitte ich möchte jetzt
einfach schon ran kommen oder haben sie
vielleicht schon eine sehr lange
warteliste wir haben schon sehr lange
warteliste wir haben das über unseren
newsletter auf der auf der webseite
gelöst und da kann man sich quasi vor
eintragen für die prio drei wenn man ein
patient bei uns ist dann wird dann
informiert sobald wir hier in der praxis
die prio 2 durch haben denn bundesweit
würden wir natürlich dass die
impfzentren mit der prior 2 fertig sind
und mit drei auch so langsam das trifft
ja aber eben nicht für das ganze
bundesgebiet zu sondern das ist ja
regional sehr unterschiedlich und jede
praxis hat im prinzip ihre liste die vor
allem nach alter geordnet ist und wir in
der hier bei uns in unserer praxis wir
sind also gerade mal bei der hälfte
vielleicht auch eine gute hälfte von der
prior 2 durch und haben noch einiges vor
die gruppen werden ja größer und die
gruppe 3 ist noch größer und vordrängeln
ist natürlich immer wieder ein thema
vordrängeln klingt auch so böse wenn man
vor planen könnte nämlich indem man
wüsste dass man solche und solche
sicheren impfstoff lieferungen kriegt
wäre das ja auch noch eine möglichkeit
die leute wollen ja vor allem nicht nur
schnell eine impfung sondern einen
abschließenden termin das würde ja
vielen auch schon helfen und reichen
wenn sie die möglichkeit hätten dem
gesundheitsminister sparen
sich ja vielleicht ein wunsch zu
erfüllen zu lassen oder zu fragen was
würden sie ihn fragen beziehungsweise
was würden sie sich von ihm wissen schon
was das impfen aus ihrer sicht auch
voranbringen würde man genau das was ich
jetzt hier schon mehrmals erwähnt habe
wenn er uns klar als hausärztin sagen
könnte ihr könnt sicher so und so viel
impfstoff bestellen und das bild für die
nächsten zwei drei vier monate
es gibt keine reduktion dann wäre uns
der hausarztpraxis schon sehr geholfen
und die planbarkeit wäre einfach
deutlich besser ja jetzt ist glaube ich
die verbindung wirklich hab leider
nichts mehr hören können aber ich
bedanke mich bei ihnen dr
für ihre einschätzung und ihre meinung
und möchte mich auch bei euch und ihnen
verabschieden vielen dank dass ihr
zugeschaut habt und auch für eure
kommentare und vielen fragen und wir
zeigen jetzt noch eine kurze
zusammenfassung mit den o-tönen aus der
pressekonferenz als kleine
zusammenfassung bitte schön wie ein
luftballon gehen wir zusammen und ich
haben sich erhalten und das tun wir
gemeinsam mit diesem kraftakt den wir
seit vielen monaten durchhalten um im
bild zu bleiben wenn wir den ballon
jetzt loslassen springt er über die
wasseroberfläche
wir dürfen also nicht ungezielt locker
der trend der letzten woche hat sich
bestätigt die dritte welle scheint
gebrochen
jetzt geht es darum den nächsten wochen
noch gemeinsam durchzuhalten wir reden
tatsächlich jetzt noch er über wochen
oder wenige monate im moment ist jeder
tag lang und hart das ist uns sehr sehr
bewusst
aber in dieser phase der pandemie geht
es eben tatsächlich weit darum weiterhin
darum das erreichte nicht zu verspielen
deswegen braucht es zuversicht gepaart
mit umsicht um menschen zu schützen zu
viel ungeduld dagegen würde nur dem
virus helfen ja mit zuversicht und keine
vorschnellen lockerungen so hat spaß
erklärt dass er versucht jetzt nicht
vorschnell zu lockern
aber eben trotzdem weiter zu hoffen und
wir uns natürlich über die sinkenden
zahlen vorhin ich bedanke mich dass ihr
heute dass sie dabei waren für ihre
fragen und kommentare
und auch für die spannenden
gesprächspartner also von mir ein vielen
dank und bis bald